hey you're gonna love this an oan host
brutally attacks me
tags the wrong David packman on
Instagram tagging a scam account
misspells my name and is generally
totally triggered here's the backstory
of this a few weeks ago I did a story
about oan host Allison Steinberg Allison
Steinberg had a conspiracy theory about
her nest thermostat I guess she rents an
apartment she moved into the apartment
there was a nest thermostat which like
every Nest Thermostat knows when you
walk by she calls it it's tracking her
in her home and she presented all sorts
of unproven conspiracy theories I did a
segment on it okay so that that was the
the video that I did we just showed you
a screenshot of it so Allison Steinberg
is furious with me and she now has done
a segment on oan imagine that this is
Trump's darling oan attacking me you'll
notice my name isn't even spelled
correctly on the entire thing let's get
into it and what's sad is she's so
confused about these thermostats she
doesn't understand how they work take a
look at this I think you're gonna like
this as a nest thermostat installed
which I didn't really think much of
until I noticed it just started
adjusting the temperature when I wasn't
home now that's a feature you can turn
on and off okay I've had Nest
thermostats for a year there there's a
learning option where you go hey pay
attention to my activity and whether I'm
home which it Knows by whether you walk
by in front of the thermostat
and adjust for maximum efficiency lower
the temperature or allow it to go up
depending on whether it's winter or
summer this is just a sure you can turn
it on and off
what I realized this device has the
ability to actually sense your
whereabouts it immediately led me to
believe that this is yet another system
that will soon be required in probably
every new home that's built which I
personally find deeply disturbing now
it's just HomeSense that's what it's
called you you can tell it
sense when I'm home or not you can turn
it off it's no big deal
it was then that I made this video
expressing my concerns over the
technology but instead of playing you my
video I'm just going to go ahead and
show you a video of my video that's
right David Pacman a soy infused
triggered leftist I had to say about you
know what's funny is I don't really eat
soy I mean every once in a while I have
you know like mapo tofu but I where is
this soy thing coming from Bart
thermostats tracking you was super
posturous it was Preposterous that he
made a whole video making fun of me for
thinking that globalists were tracking
me watch oh and please while you're
watching make note of his extremely and
utterly pathetic attempt at an Alex
Jones impression yeah okay so then she
plays my entire clip which we're gonna
skip over because you already know my
clip I'm not gonna play her playing my
clip okay so and then now we get back to
her commentary and you just have to
listen to this stuff hey David we get it
you think I'm a crazy conspiracy theory
is tin foil hat wearing Alex Jones
worshiping weirdo yes which I actually
gives a massive compliment
I actually am all of those things I want
to tell you David that
normally was Alex Jones right but so was
Allison Steinberg well when thousands of
excel customers in Colorado tried
adjusting their thermostats Tuesday they
learned they couldn't Denver seven
consumer investigator Jacqueline Allen
talked with some of those customers
Jacqueline they're upset they had no
control over the temp in their own home
that's right and you know Excel is
calling calling this a rare Energy
emergency and yes they took over tens of
thousands of smart thermostats here in
Colorado for the first time there was
nothing homeowners could do about it
well shucks now Allison Steinberg is so
clueless that she doesn't understand
that's a voluntary Colorado rewards
program
it's it's not mandatory
do you understand what you're signing up
for okay in Colorado they had this
program where if you opt in with your
smart thermostat it's your choice
Freedom okay if you opt in to let them
set your temperature during so-called
energy emergencies you get a hundred
dollar credit and 25 bucks a year
it's optional there's no there's no
subterfuge people chose to do that are
the people too dumb to understand what
they're even signing up for well that
may be the case but it's not really a
conspiracy what do you know looks like
conspiracy theorists win again now what
do you have to say for yourself David I
I just said it this is a program people
chose to participate in I think you owe
me an apology along with about 22 000
other people oh my God talarico tried to
crank up the AC I mean it was 90 out and
it was right during the peak period
that's when he found out he had no
control of his thermostat a message from
Excel on his thermostat saying
temperature locked during an energy
emergency and our thermostat was locked
in at 78 or 79 turns out he's not alone
Excel confirms to contact number seven
22
000 customers were locked out of their
smart thermostats for hours on Tuesday
because they opted into the program by
choice to get get a hundred bucks and
then 25 a year to me an emergency means
there is you know life limb or you know
some other danger out there some limb
Mass wildfires he says you have no idea
locked thermostats came with that and
it's not what he signed up for and just
doesn't sit right with us to not be able
to control our own it quite literally is
what he signed up for I understand her
house you see David when I say
globalists I'm not just referring to the
top one percent upper echelons of
society ah I'm also talking about all of
their minions who are too dumbed down to
figure out what's going on and are
complicit in aiding said globalists and
carrying out and ushering in their
agenda I guess that's me
and by agenda I mean creating a spy
State and a social credit system all to
keep you safe can you imagine we sell it
as convenience oh look how cool this is
you don't have to worry about
remembering to turn off your air anymore
save money on your outrageously high
energy bills do you think she's figured
out that these are just settings on her
nest and she can turn all of them off
first you have double cross and let your
smart thermostat shut off while you're
away the same people who are creating
the problem are selling you the solution
big Tech and private companies are
teaming up to put you in a high-tech
social credit score prison and it's
honestly not even really a conspiracy at
this point now that we have dictators
like Governor griesball telling us when
we can and can't use our AC and home
appliances and today so she cuts to
Gavin Newsom the funny thing is this has
nothing to do with just Democratic
Governors Texas is you know Texas has
this ercot system where they've decided
to isolate their electrical grid and so
there's storms in the winter and nobody
has power it's crazy what Texas has done
Texas's energy grid patriotic
independent their Energy company they
did the same thing okay they did the
exact same thing and we covered it at
the time Texas's largest energy
companies say they adjust some customers
thermostats due to grid conditions
consumers say they weren't aware they
opted into such a program it's the same
thing with the Republican Governor it's
user error the customers don't know what
the hell they're opting into and she
wants to pretend it's globalish
foreign and Gavin Newsom and Democrats
it's just user error and people who
don't know what the hell they're doing
and tomorrow afternoon after 4 P.M in
particular 4 P.M please turn your
thermostat up to 78 degrees or higher
and avoid to the extent possible using
any really large appliances now since
we've determined that Alex Jones is more
often than not pretty much always right
remember she made fun of me for saying
that she's just an Alex Jones wannabe
and now this is the third time in the
video she says Alex Jones is right about
basically everything let's go ahead and
take a little trip back to 2004. all
right so then she goes to a report from
Alex Jones let's now get to the final
part of this which is Allison's advice
to me
well there you have it folks I don't
know what more you need to see they
started cultivating this technology
decades ago and the creators are
literally telling you exactly what
they're doing but sure go ahead David
keep drinking your soy and getting your
poison shots and believing everything
the media tells you whatever you do
definitely don't question anything ever
I'm questioning this but if you do see
this video I would just like to make a
couple of very small requests one please
stop uploading my content so you can
monetize it I could say the same to you
I believe you owe me some cash now along
with your apology and two for the love
of God
pre-recorded sound bites impersonating
Alex Jones because quite frankly they
suck and you sound nothing like him move
if you're gonna make fun of someone at
least do a decent job okay oh and last
thing your button up sweater vests have
got to go I don't have any button-up
sweater vests I I don't know what she's
talking about
you're already affiliated with the party
who's in support of maps so I would hate
for people to think that you're one of
them just saying
so anyway there is Allison Steinberg and
by the way Maps is like minor attracted
persons it's like a code word for
pedophile which is uh it's sort of their
playbook just call anybody you disagree
with a pedophile so extraordinarily
interesting stuff and one other little
funny note in her post she tags an
account called David Pacman show fan
with no followers that she thinks is me
and she couldn't even I mean it's crazy
every detail is crazy she tagged a Spam
impersonation account of me when she
uploaded this video scary stuff we'll
have this clip on our Instagram at
davidpackman show